push down
pull it out okay let's do that one more
time zacky lightsaber reviews are never
easy
what's up guys i'm bobby i'm back here
in the geek culture studio we had a lot
of fun unboxing the mandalorian helmet
review and uh the guys asked me back if
i would be
interested to do the global unboxing of
ahsoka tano's lightsaber from hasbro the
force
effects elite version and i said of
course i want to see this because you
know i mean i am a fan of more of the
movie uh canon in terms of you know
obviously the nine films and then the
mandalorian where i saw socatano in
there with the white sabers
however this is a little bit different
i'll talk about that later on the review
but i was interested to see what hasbro
pulse is doing with the new lightsabers
because i am interested in the dark
saber when it comes out and i thought
this would be a good segue into that
because you got to start building the
lightsaber sooner or later and it's
always been a dream of mine as a kid to
have a lightsaber so now this is my
chance to unbox it anyway what we're
going to do we're going to do an
unboxing we're going to walk through all
the settings on this how it works and
for a lot of you out there to want to
compare it we actually have two force
effects sabers from 2007 the darth vader
and luke skywalker plus the galaxy edge
customizable version with that and we'll
compare all those sabres with this to
see which one is right for you well of
course the 2007 ones are hardly
available and if you can get them on
ebay they're going to cost a pretty
penny so this might be your best bet but
nonetheless
let's kick things off and big thanks to
hasbro for allowing us to be
the first
in the world
to unbox this bad boy all right zach you
ready yeah
what happened man did your underwear too
tight
you don't sound like that
i see your videos you have a deep sexy
voice
yeah there we go now we're talking get
me excited with my saber here all right
so let's look at the box here for a
second of course the star wars uh star
wars the black series on this now one
thing you're going to take notice of
here if you're thinking that this is the
mandalorian version it is not ahsoka
tano is not rosario darcen it is some
model they put in makeup it's not even
the animation version so
having said that you're not going to get
the white saber in this it's not even
going to be the hilt because after she
got into that battle with the darth maul
then she lost her sabers she had to
rebuild them you're not getting that
saber you're getting the pre-darth maul
version of these okay and you're only
getting one in the box so if you want to
be a socatano you need two that means
you gotta buy two sabres
these don't come cheap save your money
if you need to but if you're just a
collector one should be good enough all
right uh looking through the box though
you do see the saber right there it's
for suffix elite this time the 2021
edition we'll show you the various
different colors you get the uh kind of
the lime green or
almost yellowish green you get the blue
and you get the green color on that it
obviously talks about the various
different effects we'll swivel this
around that didn't hurt me at all
we've got here
you can change all the blades got
progressive lighting on this you got
clash effects you've got a kyber crystal
in this as well now
we'll talk about how this kyber crystal
works it is
different from the galaxy edge version
of it but nonetheless it's cool they put
it inside there and you can also change
the color of the kyber crystal to the
blue the uh yellowish green and the
green and also you get a stand as well
and the sand is not laying down a
horizontal it is vertical which is also
a nice effect to that so
that's the box in a nutshell 14 and
above
so
if you're a kid you're young anakin
from the phantom menace you can't play
with this
you can you have to be a certain age so
now this has been unboxed by the geek
culture team already because they got to
see if it works or not because if it
doesn't wait to send it back to house
bro it does work
spoiler alert anyway let's open this up
and let's see what we've got inside
let's walk through in a second
instruction manual
how to use the saber trust me you're
going to want to read this i'll walk you
through how to set it up
it is a little bit um
it takes a little time a little patience
because there's some things you have to
put together and how it works you've got
your saber back here of course this is
not a combat ready saber so don't go
beating up your neighbor your wife or
husband or girlfriend or boyfriend
but they have a you know just don't do
it just put on the wall swing it around
and have some fun but that's as far as
you want to go of course you got the
hill tier kyber crystal you got your
stand here and you got this um
thingamajig which is like a screw thing
i'll show you how that works because if
you lose this
you're basically screwed pun intended
you guys want to see the hilt that's one
of the most important things on a saber
actually is the most important thing
here it is we put this aside real quick
this is the hilt this is metal
and it feels very well constructed
i will tell you that this is uh pretty
accurate to her hilt that she was using
in the clone wars prior to her
fight with darth maul
so obviously her sabers changed after
that and you will be able to tell right
away
that this is made in china if you're
wondering because
all of the information is massively
written on the bottom of this hilt right
there so everything from lucasfilms to
all your coding to usa california
everything so obviously
yeah i mean again not a big deal you
have to look at the bottom of the hilt
but if you are one of those that likes a
very clean look to your saber
you might be a little bit perturbed
about this but it's not a deal breaker
in my personal opinion
moving up on the saber here you got your
buttons here
this is the power button here now
if you
bite your nails
if you have very fat fingers
if
you had a manicure and they cut too
short
you're gonna have a hard time using the
saber
uh i'll tell you why in just a bit when
we power it all up but it is a little
bit challenging with this button it's
different than the
previous force effects sabers but
something to take note of then also you
have this other button here which gives
you more of your sound effects we'll
show you that and sort of lighting
effects there and that's pretty much it
but it does feel really well constructed
it's not too heavy uh very well balanced
if you want to swing it around i'm not
going to do it too much here because
there's a lot of expensive collectibles
and i don't want to break anything the
finishing is pretty good some of the
edges are a little bit sharp but we'll
talk about that later on in the review
moving on let's show you the kyber
crystal here for a second unlike the
galaxy edge version it is not rfid tag
so you cannot put different kyber
crystals in a lightsaber and it will
change colors no powers on based on this
and you can get your various colors
through that but
this is it
and it's just more for show than
anything else it doesn't stay in the
saber when you're actually plugging the
blade you'll find out just a bit when we
put that all together uh here is the
stand now this stand is actually really
nice it's a metal construction feels
really well made
um what's cool about this though or
what's interesting what's cool about it
is actually that it's vertical so you
put your saver up like this so if i want
to
okay let me do this for a second
i'm gonna be starting on the saber right
that's the wrong way to do it
hold on a second i gotta take this piece
out
okay there we go so as you can tell
this thing goes like this
that's cool right
however
there's something a little inaccurate
about this stand that i think some of
you are going to see when you look at
this closely
look at the design right here
that's something from the death star
last i figured osoko was not part of the
empire was she
it's a small thing but overall the stand
looks really cool
and yeah that's the only way you can do
it there's no horizontal way you can lay
it down
right can't do it that way zacky doesn't
work nope doesn't work at all don't want
to try it we'll break your save all
right so let's get the saber out here on
this real quick okay so we take the
blade out
and we'll put that to the side
and that's pretty much everything here
now this blade is uh very lightweight
again this is not a combat ready blade
so uh if you do have a combat a saber
and you want to try this out i wouldn't
recommend it uh so just keep that in
mind but this is good for just even when
we're playing things like this this is
fine but anything like when you're
whacking the saber go full on i wouldn't
recommend it start off with this we
already put batteries in this just to
sort of speed things up
now
you can press the power button
and it'll give that sound when the
blade's not in
okay
sounds good speakers are pretty loud i
have to say
oh very loud um now of course it depends
on your battery level as soon as your
battery starts draining the power you
will notice a little difference in sound
happens with all the sabers anyway but
this sounds really good um but as you
could tell i was really trying to get my
finger in that uh
this little area to turn it on because
it's very narrow
very narrow
that sounded wrong dude it sounded good
that sounded very wrong
we actually have a piece here so what
you want to do this piece is integral to
actually putting in some pieces so we're
going to put the kyber crystal in first
so as you can tell you've got some
grooves here and then you've got this
sort of mechanism inside so you want to
do is try to find it
and you want to unscrew this piece
let's do this real quick
am i doing this right
there we go i'm doing this right
that piece you got to take out do not
lose this piece whatever you do because
it is integral so let's put in the kyber
crystal first to show you how this works
so we're going to do is you're going to
drop it in
and just going to kind of maneuver it
until it kind of drops
just kind of turn it around a little bit
drops lock it in
and now
[Music]
different sound and you can actually see
the kyber crystal inside of it
now right now it's turned to blue if you
want to change the colors of it what
you're going to do is hold the power
button and this orange button here
together
[Music]
so now it's green
there we go now it's a darker green yeah
so you can change the colors that way
then what you do is you if you want to
take it out to see what the kyber
crystal looks like okay you can see it's
a little bit green i think about to turn
off the lights for you to see it because
it's very faint so zach you turn it off
it's just ever so lightly lit
it's not going to light up anything for
that matter but it's just a little bit
of hint of green and it will fade over
time so this is just more aesthetic just
something to show off once in a while
but to be frank with you in my personal
opinion once you do this a couple of
times that's it you're gonna put on the
shelf and you're gonna forget about it
because
you're either gonna display this maybe
the kyber crystal next to it and the
blade but i don't think you're gonna be
taking this in and out to light it up so
um unfortunately i wish this was battery
powered so in a button next to it so you
could actually change the colors that
would be kind of a cool display to have
the lightsaber on the display plus the
kyber crystal with the uh the color that
you'd like it to be but that is not the
case this powers it this charges it up
but it only stays on for a little bit of
time let's
put the saber in the moment of truth
so
as i said don't lose this especially if
you want to put the saber on
so how this works is
and take this in
push and lock it turn the lock now it's
pretty secure but you want to put this
metal piece on top
and lock this in because
you don't want your blade to come out on
accident
and then you got to take this screw
piece
yup bear with me guys are you following
me why this is a little bit uh
difficult
the moment of truth
[Music]
look at that
this is the yellowish green so
technically
this would be the chotto color right
it's yellowish green
as you can tell pretty responsible
the light is pretty bright it's not
overly bright but it's decent enough
okay
very good effects i think it's got a
gyroscope in there sounds like it
then of course then we have this orange
button here which
if you want to burn through a wall
saber clasp
you have this effect
blaster shots
and it shoots white
then
you want to change the color
[Music]
to blue
[Music]
so it's actually in terms of the balance
this is actually quite light so i think
i'm not going to swing around too much
here because i don't want to break
anything but
it feels actually really good in my
personal opinion i wish this was a
little bit brighter now it might look
brighter to you on camera because of the
video aspect of it but in person
it's not that bright so i mean if you're
in a dark room of course it's going to
be pretty pretty bright but i think
according to other sabers i've seen out
there i think this is more on the medium
to dimmer side of things
so
but it's got a lot of cool effects like
this right here is pretty interesting
the sound is good as well i mean the
speakers are really good here but yeah i
wish it was a little bit brighter
anyway
that's pretty much the osokatano saber
on this and uh yeah i mean it feels good
very well balanced
no it doesn't change the white
it doesn't change the white zacky yeah
that's
that's something well if you want a
white you just turn it off that's how
you get white
so you can turn it back on
actually we'll make the saber white
right now go zacky go it's white
see how we did it see how we did it
i wish hasbro would have included that
it actually had a white light to it
because for a lot of us out there who
just followed the film canon you know
associated from that and she's got her
white sabers and then they release the
saber right after the mandalorian season
two so you think yourself well of course
it would be
that color saber but it's not gonna go
oh you want the other ahsoka tano saber
right you want the white one of course
we're gonna make it
so
save some money it's probably going to
come very soon i think for the you guys
out there that are collectors you're
going to really like this piece
especially if you're a socatano fans but
uh if you're waiting for those uh other
sabres i gotta keep doing this
[Music]
ah this tool
but one of the good things about the
saber especially in our climate here in
singapore is there's there are no rubber
bits on this
so you'll see in just a bit why i talk
about that because in singapore with our
climate here it's very humid and some of
these collectible toys can
warp and melt over time due to the heat
and you're not going to have that
problem with the ahsoka tano sabre from
hasbro on this one so good job on hasbro
for making this humidity proof now it's
comparison time we got two force effects
sabres from 2007 luke skywalker darth
vader versus ahsoka tano sabre
let's look at uh vader's for a second
here by the way you cannot take vader
sabre out on this one it is stuck inside
but as you can tell right here by the
hilt a lot of this plastic has melted uh
where it's kind of warped a little bit
you can see some of the plastic around
here there's some warpage going on this
is something that happens in our climate
it's unfortunate this is why
a lot of us that do collect hot toys we
have let's say dry cabinets or we have
our air cons you know working 24 7 so we
don't come across this but it is what it
is
in terms of the weight i would say the
vader is definitely
heavier than ahsoka thanos now of course
hilt size
vader is slightly
taller
slightly taller there's a bit more
plastic on it now it's a very hard
composite plastic it does feel pretty
good but you got a little bit of shiny
plastic here and then of course you've
got this rubber bits that have been uh
molded a little bit over time
but i would say the vader is more
substantial in weight now of course
vader saber is going to be heavier i
mean the way that he fought was
obviously different than a socatano but
uh yeah that is really some of the main
difference let's turn vader on versus
ahsoka tano
let's see how this rolls
now this is very loud as well okay and
as you can tell there's very minimal
writing here at the bottom of the hill
which i personally like i know this is a
small thing
but
i like that
this is minimalist because as a
collector's piece
we know these products are made in
various different countries but i don't
need to be written in bold lettering on
the hill you know i mean that's just my
personal opinion but i also like how
easy this is to turn on look at that
switch
on
now it's not as responsive as ahsoka
tunnels but again this is 2007 versus
2021 so there is going to be a
difference in technology that's in these
sabers but the audio sounds fantastic
actually let's turn off the light zacky
let's see how these blades light up
against each other
[Music]
so in terms of light i would say
vader could be slightly brighter
just slightly
[Music]
you see how responsive this is
vader's a little
it's okay not bad
i feel like ahsoka's a little bit better
you see there's a little difference
but that's pretty much all you can do
with this one on this point i mean
there's really not much you can do
versus this one
you've got the led effects happening in
the saber on vader's obviously the led
technology wasn't as good in 2007 as it
is in 220 2021 so you are going to miss
out on some of those effects
but
it is
easier to turn off
than katana
let's hold that down for a second
okay now we're in a different ball game
folks
luke obviously is not as strong as his
dad
for obvious reason this is much lighter
than vader's
still has the same
concept of turning it on
now the battery on this is maybe not as
strong as the vader because the sound is
not as loud right
you can remove this blade as well and
i'll show you how that happens in terms
of build quality though
i would say looking at this
i got to give it to the new uh
sabre fro the socatanos one from forcefx
elite because even this pla this kind of
piece right here just feels a little bit
off in terms of the metal and the design
now of course they're trying to be
accurate and you know back when they
made these sabers in the 70s they
weren't as refined as they are today in
terms of design and concept but uh yeah
it's
it's not bad i mean it's luke skywalker
so you're gonna get luke skywalker saber
no matter what this is like
you know
you want to savor you want luke's
but
yeah it's actually not too bad let's
turn on the uh let's do blue versus blue
zach let's turn off the light again
so i always say on this one and i could
say ahsoka tunnels is slightly brighter
uh but again this could be a battery
thing with this uh sabre so i don't want
to discount luke's on this
but in terms of responsiveness
you see the difference
[Music]
so this is not as responsive of course
as luke's
and
you do get that
you go to snaps but you see how they get
the white lights on ashoka tanos nothing
on loops just sound
that's the same with vader's as well
that's very cool right
build quality i gave it to the new one
design wise i think materials wise i got
to give to the new one as well so in
terms of removing this lightsaber it's
actually a lot easier than this one
you're gonna see so all you do is
unscrew this portion here and then once
you've got that portion pull it out and
you just
pull the saber that's it
there's no plastic thingamajig you need
to slide down the saber to unscrew the
metal piece and take it out it's just
very very simple
if you want to put it back in
it makes a sound let you know that it's
clicked in
and then
just
screw it back in like that
a few moments later
please go in 2007 products but yeah
that's it so that's pretty much uh
how you handle the luke skywalker saver
on that okay
so now that we covered the two force
effect sabers
let's
move on to the galaxy edge saver for
price point's sake these two are very
comparable in terms of price point now
not everybody can go to galaxy's edge
right now because of course what's
happening around the world but for those
of you who live near disneyland in
florida or in california
we all envy you here at geek culture
because you have access to this we don't
but luckily someone brought this in
before our travel stopped so we were
able to have one here in
the studio
now just first impressions is actually
the first time i've actually really been
playing with a galaxy's edge saber and i
gotta say this is quite amazing if you
guys have never held one this is massive
this is heavy your arms are gonna be
yoked in no time right zacky yeah can
you turn it on
just makes a little bit of a sound
but there's no saber inside but there's
a kyber crystal inside so what's
interesting about the uh the galaxy edge
saber with the kyber crystal inside you
can actually change the color of the
blade based on the kyber crystal that's
not the same with the ahsoka tanos one
as i showed you before it's just more
for
visual effects and just kind of a fun
thing to show off but this has more
usability inside of it but of course to
get to the kyber crystal
requires a lot of removing of parts so
since we're doing a comparison
let's go through that now
take off the bottom
take off the top
you can do a top or bottom
doesn't make a difference
then you can move
this side here
this side here
[Music]
then you can just pull this off it's
magnetic
and there's your crystal inside
so
there you go and then if you want to see
how it lights up just press the battery
pack here
beautiful cue zacky that was great
fantastic look at that look at that
dimming effect you have there
cinematic look at that powder crystal
now this actually is brighter than the
one that comes with the asuka tunnel one
and of course as i mentioned before you
can change the crystal and it gives you
a whole different personality to your
saber now let's put the blade in all you
do is kind of just turn it on
lock it in makes that sound
and
[Music]
this sounds badass i want to be frank
with you
this sounds pretty amazing
so to put them close together you can
see the build quality is different the
galaxy edge version is longer but of
course you can customize your hilt to
whatever you like it to be
now in terms of the two sabers here
let's move over here for a second you're
gonna notice that the galaxy's edge is a
bit longer but again you can customize
this to your size liking uh this the
ahsoka tanos is lighter and it feels a
little bit more responsive in terms of
its sound it's not bad as well
so you are going to get some sort of uh
sound and sort of light effects and i
will say the assokatano is a little bit
more responsive than the galaxy's edge
version
but the audio from this galaxy's edge
version is so nice
this is really really nice
um
but they seem to be almost like the same
blade if you look at them on the front
of it so
[Applause]
these are a very close call on this i
guess
it really depends if you have the option
to go to disneyland
this might be a good option to get into
i mean you're going to get it anyway
probably have a few savers you're not
going to have one
but
the sukatano one
i mean when you compare them all these
are really good now i will say on the
galaxy's edge this switch is very easy
to knock so you have to be careful on
that the one thing is while i did was uh
sort of criticizing this as being
difficult to turn on because of the
grooves being very narrow to get your
finger inside it actually does make it
so you don't accidentally turn off this
saber so easily so that's one of the
positives so i guess hasbro was thinking
okay do we want you to turn your saber
off and on easily or do they want we
want to make it a little more difficult
you have to work hard for your saber and
i guess the option for the work hard for
your saber moment
does that sound right tacky
[Music]
now one thing i do want to talk about
between these two sabers is of course
the stands now this is sold separately
this one comes with the saber
but i gotta hand it to uh
galaxy's edge here they've done a
fantastic job this is metal it's very
durable you can adjust these spaces
where you want them to be let me just
take off the saber here
and just lay it down
at that that is very cool i think for
some of you out there that if you have a
large cabinet you want to have the blade
on this so that it will actually work
depending on the size of your cabinet so
technically if geek culture didn't have
all these great toys in here we just
want to do one long stretch you could do
that with the saber inside
however with the socatanos
not going to happen i do wish there was
a horizontal option for this is it at
this time maybe they'll sell a stand
separately or you can purchase one on
ebay or somewhere else that you can put
it on but it is what it is but i will
say
this makes the choice if you had to
choose between one of these much more
difficult
but overall i gotta say that this is uh
this is a fun little saber this is fun i
think for collectors out there who are
big fans of ahsoka tano that want her
saber i think this is one to get of
course you need two so you have to buy
two you can just have one and the house
didn't give you a package kit set with
that so you have to buy double
it is what it is but i can't wait for
the dark saber and i know a lot of you
out there have already pre-ordered the
dark saber and are big fans of that i am
as well
but uh yeah i'll definitely uh this
would be one for the collector's kit for
sure
so final thoughts on this saver here i
mean
yeah i do wish the button was a little
bit bigger so it was easier to turn on
but i do understand why hasbro did it
this orange button here
it's not bad i mean i wish it was a
little bit uh more solid in terms of his
build quality but overall the weights of
this feels good um very well balanced i
mean if you want to do some sort of
cosplay with this you want to swing it
around you're much more talented with a
saber than i am then i think you're
gonna have a lot of fun with this um
again it's not a combat ready saber so
please don't go out there whacking
things because if you break it
yeah it's gonna be expensive to replace
this
but overall i think uh house was done a
pretty good job with this overall i just
gotta remove the stickers here
and yeah i think uh stand wise
legitimate
it's an empire stand though but it is
what it is
uh but yeah overall i highly recommend
this and i think this is a really good
stepping stone into
the dark saber that's coming out from
hasbro pulse very very soon
i'm hearing from the guys here good
culture that is going to be coming in
and we may get a global first unboxing
of that
just putting that out there and maybe
they'll invite me back who knows thank
you so much for joining us and let me
know any questions you have in the
comment section below
if uh if you want us to play around with
this more compared to other savers we'll
try to do what we can again we're in
singapore so we don't have access to all
the great sabers everybody else does but
we will do our best and with that guys
stay safe take care and we'll chat to
you soon
look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
okay i'm doing my saber
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]